you said that really you don't believe
there are mass people and not mass
people but you know you'll need to
convince you know sorry let me let me
rephrase that um so you don't believe
really that you know some people are
mass people and there are others people
who should just give up on math but a
lot of other people need to be convinced
about that they're very convinced that
they're not not math people so how do
you go about convincing someone who has
that mindset that there's nothing in it
for them that math could be of interest
and perhaps they should think more
mathematically well I think the first
thing not to do is to whack them over
your head with a textbook and say you're
wrong because that is patently an
unhelpful way to respond to quite
frankly a lot of people's trauma in the
way that they learned mathematics I'll
never forget running a workshop in
region New South Wales and a lovely very
small 80-year-old woman coming out to
the front of the hall after the the
event was finished and she said I wish
mat was taught the way you taught it
when I was younger when I was taught it
we would all write our answers to a
question on our hand and our teacher
would say Okay raise your hands now
everyone and show me the answer that
you've got so I can read it and then my
teacher would go out the front to her
desk she would open a drawer and she'd
pull out her
cane and if any of us had the wrong
answer on our hand we never forgot it
for the rest of our lives there's a lot
of maybe not that extreme but some
version of that no no one likes to feel
stupid no one likes being placed under
that pressure of goodness me I don't
know the answer to this i' must be an
idiot I can't learn this stuff and so
the first thing to do is to acknowledge
there's some pain and difficulty and
struggle underneath that that I want to
empathize with and say I get it the
feeling that you have that mass is not
for you is
really plausible I understand it I don't
want to dismiss it but
or rather
and there is a way to connect maths to
you you just don't know it yet so
mathematics can have a reputation for
being abstract because the way that we
often teach it is in symbols in x's and
y's that quite deliberately obscure what
it is that those x's and y's stand for
are these population numbers are they
Heights are they temperatures the fact
that they're X and y's are the point is
that they could be anything and that's
that's where their superpower comes from
mathematics has this universality that
is why it's used in every Endeavor that
humans have ever been interested in
because it can solve any kind of problem
but that abstractness is a two-edged
sword it can make it feel like it has
nothing to do with anything that I care
about and I remember once a conversation
I had right before I gave a TED Talk at
uh the International Convention Center
in Sydney and I was the first talk and
myself and a musician her name was adet
she's a Pianist and and a singer very
very gifted she was the first performer
and so we were standing backstage
waiting for the call and we had a lot of
time on our hands because it was one of
those hurry up and wait type situations
where call time was an hour before we
were actually do to get on stage and so
we had the opportunity to actually have
a real conversation and she said to me
so what what do you do
and I said like I'm a math teacher and
frankly that's usually the end of the
conversation in most cases but because
we had 34 an hour at this point to wait
I I just sort of explained you know this
is what I do and she said to me oh I
could never do math I just I just hate
the subject and because I had the time I
said to her tell me tell me what it
means to me to you rather to be a
musician what what does what does
composing look like to you what what
makes a great song and she started to
explain to me about about the meaning of
of rhythms and and Melodies and
harmonies and how they all fit together
in a beautiful Symmetry and the
structure of a song and I said to
her that is all
mathematics
mathematics is like music to the mind in
the way that music is like mathematics
to the soul and so being able to say
okay for you your world is music I know
enough about mathematics to connect my
world to yours I think every teacher of
any subject but particularly mathematics
has a
responsibility and privilege of being
able to say you don't know how this is
connected to you but let me show you you
know parents are so invested in their
children and these important
developmental years particularly at
school do you think parents should be
confident that our school curriculums
are up to the task of uh teaching the
transferable skills and the critical
mindsets that children are going to need
when they graduate into this rapid fast
changing
world I simple answer to that question
even though there isn't a simple answer
this question is yes they are I do
remember the first time that uh a
academic I won't name her because this
is a stat which she might not be happy
with me pinning against her name but she
said to me uh in a very um in a moment
of great trust and I really appreciated
her saying this to me but I felt rattled
by it when she was talking about the
culum that you're just referring to she
said Eddie you need to understand
curriculum syllabus documents they are
not documents that have been crafted to
provide students with the best learning
experience they are objects that have
been created through a political process
to satisfy the stakeholders at play many
of whom have competing and sometimes
contradictory priorities and what you
have in your hands as a teacher is
almost a a Frankenstein esque
composition of different ideas some of
which are truly clashing with each other
that you should not have rose-colored
glasses on when you read it's it's a
document that's been borne out of this
very pragmatic process and I was rattled
by that statement because as a much
younger more idealistic naive I would
say teacher I thought well if if that's
the case what hope do we have to your
point before is this going to be enough
for students can I Can I with my hand on
my heart say that I can use this to
provide students with what they need
moving forward and I came to realize the
answer is yes because despite coming to
us by such a
roundabout uh strange securist process
actually enough thought
design and intent have gone into
certainly within Australia and a lot of
the international jurisdictions I've
looked at from the UK US Singapore you
know there's a bunch of different ones
which all look different but they share
enough in common that actually
they are a launching off point for the
teacher and for the student themselves
to be able to say here are the the
foundational Concepts the places that if
I'm imagining giving a tour of Europe
you would say look down this
Alleyway there's a thousand years of
history in this pavement Now look up
cast your eyes to that cathedral in the
distance we're not going to get there
today
but let me tell you what you should look
out for when you start heading in that
direction and then there are mountains
beyond that which you will only be able
to experience if you understand where
you are situated and how to get there
and how they're all related to each
other there is plenty of wonderful
material certainly in the syllabus that
I have the privilege of teaching that
does give me great hope in fact more
than hope confidence yeah that when used
well equip students for whatever future
is coming for them we've got to wrap up
but but I want you to give two pieces of
advice if we can um I mean you are you
know we're talking in Australia you're
Australia's most famous teacher in
Australia and you're the teacher in
Australia who has more Global
recognition than anyone else so you know
if you're a parent engaged with your
child and wanting to equip your children
to be lifelong learners you what advice
to those
parents sometimes the ad the advice
we're best at giving is the one we need
to pay attention to ourselves I love
that my one of my favorite lines is we
teach best that which we most need to
learn right so what do you need to learn
as a parent well I think of my two high
school age children and my one primary
school age child and I think in fact I
don't just think I remember to those
moments that my children themselves have
told me have been most instrumental in
helping them to to move forward as
Learners particularly through for
example some of the the tricky years
we've experienced through this Global
pandemic and the very different position
that it placed parents in uh in helping
to cultivate their child's learning and
I've realized
that most of what I've been able to give
my children that has been of most value
value to them and I hope this
gives positivity to our
listeners they've not come from any of
my training as a
teacher they've come
from my priority on empathy to my fellow
human being because I think that the
most valuable thing that we as parents
can give to our
children is to come alongside them and
to
say
hey what is that tell me about that
explain to me this poem that you're
reading with some embarrassment despite
the fact that I love English and I
studied it to the highest level possible
in new souths high schools I never
really wrapped my head around poetry
when I was at school and I regretted
that I went through many years of my
life thinking well that's just a door
that's closed forever and it was with
delight that my daughter came home with
a poem from Yates and she said we're
learning this and it's amazing and in
that moment I had a choice I could say
number one okay and then move on with
the hundred different things that I had
to do that day and not pay any further
attention number two I could say poetry
I hated poetry good luck with that or
number three and obviously there's a a
spectrum of infinite different options
here but number three what I chose to do
and what I know she found valuable was
to sit beside my daughter and to have
her explain to me to be in the position
of the learner with her because that
posture and that time signaled to her
more than any pedagogical technique or
strategy I ever learned at University or
came to learn while I was an inservice
teacher more than any of those it
reaffirmed to her the value and the
Dignity of what she was doing and
therefore it was worth
her precious time and effort and even
more than that I would think it's almost
like the reverse of what you were saying
about fan the fact that she needs to be
able to explain that to you that you're
turning yourself into a learner but
you're helping her become a teacher and
to to think and to be able to explain
that complexity to you is an important
part of The Learning Experience for her
as as well what advice to the students
who are listening you know who have a
life of learning ahead we run
graduations here at the University we
say it's not a Finishing Line it's just
a milestone you're going to be learning
forever so you know what do they need to
do to be fully equipped to be lifelong
Learners I think having an
attitude of knowing that you will learn
something from everything it might be by
counter example but you will truly learn
something from every different life
experience that you're ever going to
encounter and in some ways you're going
to learn the most when you expect it the
least and my favorite example of this is
that I'm a bit of an audio junkie I'm
not just saying that because we're on a
podcast right now but I am someone who
listens to an Eclectic mix of different
podcasts and one of the things I love
about that is that I love surprising
myself with something that looks like
it'll have no interest to
me no connection to what it is that I
have to do that I I want to become
better at but I'll suspend judgment long
enough to hit download to listen in and
without exception I find ideas that
cross over with my world in ways that I
never anticipated this happens to me
enough that I now know to expect if I
think there's nothing to do with me in
this then uh I just need to give it a
bit of
time I'm Mark Scott Vice Chancellor of
the University of Sydney and a huge
thanks to Eddie woo for his insights
today Eddie is Professor of practice in
the school of education at the
University of Sydney a high school math
teacher and one of my all-time favorite
YouTubers make sure you're following the
solutionists in your favorite podcast
app so you never miss a chance to meet
the brightest Minds working to solve the
most complex issues the people who are
making change happen